[Music]
most respected
show thank you guys for tuning in now
will you accept this challenge
by hitting a thumbs up and the bell
button you laugh
you lose let's freaking do this guy
together we can do it together we are
strong do not scout that
i'm looking at you how you doing baby
why is this a meme like i see it
everywhere it's
not even i gotta find the original he's
like in a pool with an ak or something
is it real is it
real where's the original and try
because he's in a
swimming pool or jacuzzi or something
okay it isn't oh club is looking at her
nothing like a good old jacuzzi bath
with your fellow ak it looks so tough
oh my god i gotta do i gotta do a video
on my boy my boy let me just get
[Music]
a six nine six nine i'm taking my class
this video
this meme really took off huh
oh uh who posted it first that's right
everybody i get extra meme points
i really would love to see some sort of
meme currency
if anyone can please invent a meme
currency that
puts a new any meme it's like a stock
right and you can invest
in the meme stock this i know this is a
billion dollar idea because this is a
rebound meme like there's an older meme
coming back so let's say you had
invested in this meme and then it takes
off
bam millionaires
saw their ads on my tv thought about
going but was too lazy now instead of
looking flying rolling fat
my legs are sticking to the i don't know
i don't like this meme
i'm sorry beautiful painting you got
there
too bad it's the wrong one
[Music]
this is the painting you got the wrong
painting i don't know they look exactly
alike silence fools
this is gone long enough this painting
clearly causes badness in men
and it must be destroyed nope
no destroying that painting that's a
piece of history
i painted this what
oh no why am i in there
cause he wrote me into this him over
there he wrote me into this well he
wrote me into that what about me
he he wrote me into this well that one
over there wrote me into this oh he
wrote me
into that and they can only be e
okay that can only be e or b actually
now i think about it you know what
ignore me uh
let me work my magic
[Music]
every fortnight thumbnail every
this is a bucket
no not the bucket oh my god so random
whenever it's random i just can't help
myself
if you look closer it will read you are
mystic the only thing my mom used to
ever tell me was don't let people grab
my playstation
people will find a way no
god damn it are you having fun watching
this blank face then occasionally
letting out
i hope you're being entertained as much
as i am
come on give me something good
i don't know they're creative but
they're not funny okay
he's gonna grab an ak
oh hilarious again the 699
means everybody
i don't even know why i left okay and i
actually didn't live
hey i didn't like
hey it's the painting meme everybody
it's gonna be a bunker
i guarantee you there he is so beautiful
oh my god
i would love to see a meme that is just
random memes that pretends that they're
memes from the future
because literally anything is just a
meme these days you can't
you can't a point at something be like
no that's ridiculous that can never be a
meme
literally anything can be a meme which
is the beauty of memes everybody
suspect is playing on foot of course
of course
it's me connor i need to play that
stupid game but am i gonna
but are we gonna priority one
i'm hereby directing the department of
defense and pentagon
to immediately begin the process
necessary
to establish a space force
as the sixth branch of the armed forces
we must have american dominance
in space i swear trump just read
starship troopers and be like yeah
yep it's time to be the best pirate i've
ever seen
so it would seem a pirate
[Applause]
you cut before the best bit that blah
blah
copyrighted music i'm taking you in
guess he's not that great of a pirate
hey
never illegally download now concentrate
hey it's another painting meme what is
it going to be
drift across the counter what is he
going to do what are they going to do
a bunga i got my bats on a bunker
come on come on my man
my man come up come on 50 bucks
50 bucks 50 bucks on a bunga
500 500 000 5 million
ubunga my man my damn it
oh my god
[Laughter]
yes
thank you
yay i've been watching gdq for two years
now and today i just found out that my
grandpa died two hours ago
to three different types of cancer
that was amazing
there's nothing funny about dying in
mario kart
[Music]
if your name is junior and you're really
handsome come on raise your hand
all right i don't even know what to say
that was
fantastic well done all the links in the
description everybody
did you scrap that did you for lura let
me know in the comments leave a like if
you scrap that leave a like a few floor
and as always
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you